my first derivative is 2x log X plus X
yeah you can see the way I've done
products ruled there's my v u dash and
my you v dash I know by the way I would
just comment I I say it like that I am
conscious to the fact that some people
do it in the reverse order which is fine
because it's addition the reason I do it
in this order is what can anyone tell me
why I do it this one it's because it
helps me get the question will right
where the order does matter whereas here
you can put them anywhere you like
question rules different so let's move
on to which you didn't appear this quick
quiz to move on to the chain rule 1 plus
sign next to the five so you can see
there's my outside derivative yeah and
there's my inside derivative are you
happy with that yep looking good um no
no no I just found it a little bit
awkward to write it like that so
coefficient out the front 4x cubed + 1
minus cos x again you can see my v u
dash and my you v dash you got a double
negative happening there because kha'zix
differentiates into minus sine X and
there's already a negative there so
that's why I just have positive sine X
did you have to factorize again not
really we talked about this last quiz
right but it just looked messy to me so
I just walked about with a little bit
and here last one in just the straight
derivatives you can see what I've done
here's my what have I done first there's
my outside derivative yet you see that
so I brought the power out the front and
then I've reduced the power by one and
then here is my inside dream which is
chain rule but it's simple chain rule
yes are you happy with that I suppose I
could have if i wanted to said negative
sine X no hold on yeah yeah that would
have been fine um but but be that you
just ask for the derivative right you
just ask for the rivet this this is fine
yeah so said again
oh sorry I'd be confused you got this
yeah that's fine yeah it's okay which by
the way will come up for us in the
extension to exercise in a bit of let's
go down to this simple log this is what
you get so you can see again I know you
don't have to do this you may well be
able to do that in your head but this is
just a strategy i've taken for myself to
minimize silly errors i've learned not
to trust pretty piece in my head so
that's why the half comes out the front
amigo ok any questions on the first
column look good let's move over they
hand you this substitution we've
established because I rubbed it up cuz
if in fact where is it it's somewhere in
there is I just I just rub him out
anyway Oh as I have mentioned in an
extension one context you're more likely
to not be told the substitution so
therefore all you have to do is do the
necessary differentiation so you can
change the variable that you're
integrating with respect to and then
this should come out what do you guys
think yeah do that this clugston should
it be inside or outside answer is it
doesn't matter because if you have a
constant or a constant divided by a
third it's still a constant however I've
left it inside the brackets just
personally because number one I had no
reason to take it out number two if I
take it out unless it's zero it's a
different constant right so if I if I
Richard for example oh I agree but at
this point here I need the constant of
integration and I haven't done my
substitution so if i had written this
well like i said unless it's zero these
two numbers could possibly be the same
and so I really should say something
like c1 c2 and like nobody got time for
that so if I just I just left in time
okay all right it's move on to now you
see why I gave you
the reference sheet so so this question
did I did I do it wrong today do I cargo
that's okay yeah that degrees word
should have known okay so i got agree if
you're in degrees mode now can i just
ask your 12 legit question here if
you're in degrees moon what answer did
you get okay 0.9 whatever that should
tell you whoa I've gone way off like you
guys remember how quickly Newton's
method went right and they're already
telling you hey it should be close to
this right Newton's method makes feel
speed of an approximation task right um
I think I said before I think I said
before when i first introduced me this
method now because of the way it works
if you use it in the right context that
you avoid all the traps that we saw
before if you use it right you basically
double the number of decimal places and
accuracy you get with every successive
application that means if you had one
that you get to if you have for you get
eight it's just crazy that's what
calculus does for you right so that's
why I would knew I was on the right
track because I got to answer those
crazy cause take pity on people like me
who had to memorize Newton's method okay
last one the volume I'm not bitter at
all ah here's the volume ah yeah just
for what it's worth isn't it's just what
you got so yeah okay so let's just
rewind I always start this way I always
start this way it's been a little while
since you've done a volume I like to put
the pie inside because again it helps me
to remember there's a pie there it's so
easy to forget and what is this what is
this thing where does it come from it's
a formula it's that infinitesimally thin
cylinder which has a volume of PI R
squared H made you remember that so
that's that's a mechanism for me and
then I just do the straight substitution
with my bio boundaries and my function
okay so it's a straight forward
substitution bucket and hand it back to
your friend